what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel and welcome to
episode i'm not sure of the pre-game
[Music]
uh before i start do not forget to
subscribe to the channel and bring that
notification bell that way you're going
to be notified of my daily videos as you
guys
know okay if you've watched two or more
of my live streams and you don't
subscribe me and you we have beef okay b
that is not cool
it no it's not
you can't okay
it is not cool to be watching these live
streams for free and not subscribing a
subscribe is free okay free only takes
five seconds guys
not even it takes like one um so just so
you guys know every
wednesday thursday and friday i do a
live show it's called the pregame and
turn on your notifications to my channel
to be notified when we go live okay next
order of business is we have a sponsor
today it is cooking with chris
chris offers completely customized meal
plans to use you're eating foods that
you like and losing weight okay i've
been on this meal plan for like a month
um yes i have
um i've been i'm down 12 pounds right
now and literally a month yeah yeah and
i was i was down 15 but i went to
ireland and i was eating there
luckily irish
but if you guys are interested in losing
weight on a meal plan that you actually
like and enjoy eating um cooking with
chris he's the guy to go to the link is
in the description so
to start um get why don't you guys
introduce yourself say your relationship
status
and um say
where you're from yeah and if you have
any social media you want to plug okay
so i'll start there my name's innie i'm
from north london england i am married
been married happily married for nine
months now so yeah little star yeah and
um
i do have uh social media but i don't
really use it that much so if you are
going to look for me i have a youtube
page called akuma uh
kuma so called films you can find on
youtube and if you want to find me on
twitter it's inijk27
um my name is dovidas i'm originally
from lithuania i've been living in uk
for about 12 years um instagram is
davidas
golovchenko 33 or david golovchanko
and
youtube wise is why possible tv
and yeah
oh i'm single
and yeah that's what i think that's
about it
okay guys so today our
up our topic today
is dating in the church
and is marriage still a viable option in
2022.
so what are you guys thoughts on
marriage
should i go first by the way
you definitely should take the lead on
that one okay shall take the lead and
match it okay one really quick guys if
there's any audio issues let me know in
the chat just let me know how it sounds
okay
okay so yes i think marriage is the
optimum solution you know because
obviously
something that one famous red pool they
will say we're better together than we
are apart
um i think obviously with marriage we've
got to know what our roles are because i
don't believe in the equality model of
marriage that is 50 50. i believe in the
complementary model of marriage meaning
the man being the head and the woman
being the helper and if you think if
both parties know their role that's what
it could be synchronized to make the
marriage work okay what do you think
um personally sorry this is going off uh
a case of what i've seen recently like
tick tock white social media wise and a
lot of the
young couples nowadays get married very
early and that's all well and good but
like i
believe that sometimes people jump into
the whole marriage thing too early
knowing that like oh i've known this a
person for x amount of time
and
i like him and i love him and whatever
but then come to once they're married
they come to a conclusion of like oh i
think i made a mistake but it's much
harder to get out of it now so i do
believe that look marriage honestly is
the way
but i don't feel like you need to jump
into it as soon as oh i feel like i love
him and this is the man for me type
thing i need i feel like that you need
to wait out a certain x amount of time
so a year or two if we actually be like
okay this is actually the man for me
how long do you think you should date
somebody before you get married it's a
good question it's a good question i
think before you even it's not about how
long is about what support systems you
have
now i think before you get married
there's what i call the three r's you
should consider before you get married
okay one's the rational side meaning are
you guys compatible meaning that you
know
you know the social economic status
does the one person have there could you
if you marry someone else with that
because you remember once you're married
that that's yours
you've got the romantic side obviously
the lovely feeling inside you know you
feel that energy that butterflies in
your stomach and the last one's called
the religious side you've got to believe
in the same
values right because there's no point i
agree i think you mentioned it once in
your show there's no point in liberal
mind the conservatives that's a recipe
for disaster right same way a christian
should not marry a muslim or an atheist
so if you don't have those three r's i
think that's when it's more recipe for
disaster yeah what tends to happen we
just focus on the romantic side of the
feeling size but as we know feelings are
fickle yeah they'll soon wear off but
how would you make their religion the
same if there's like three girls to
every one guy in the church
that's the question because that's in my
opinion how the church kind of leaves
women single as they say they have to
have the same religion
but there's not it's like supply and
demand yeah but then again the the
question should ask is why are there
enough men in the church and my theory
behind is that the church has become too
feminized yeah i agree they focus too
much on god's love and mercy but not
much on god's justice mm-hmm you know
you know and um and if you want to get
men you got to emphasize jesus's
masculine qualities as much as jesus is
lovely and you know gentle and stuff he
was also firm there's some words where
you know you look at the bible it goes
to the tax collectors and tells them
yeah the temple that doesn't get
emphasized you see for me once i saw
that sort of jesus that's what attracted
me when i was 24 to really follow him
yeah and i think if we did that more men
will come to the church
and okay do you so a lot of people in
the red pills think that marriage is
outdated especially like legally so do
you think that it maybe should just be a
religious ceremony and people could not
legally get married i think i see some
sympathies with it the way the legal
system is structured so for example if a
man gets married and obviously has a lot
of assets and the divorce happens
woman's entitled half of his um right
yeah now i can understand what that rule
was initially um
um
was initially uh there was good
intentions behind it right so the the
fear was if a man married a woman and
the man said you know what i'm going to
trade in this mode and get a younger
model right exactly the woman become
desolate so that that the uh what's the
what's the word alimony that's not what
it's called right was put in there to
say that okay if the man does you know
nukes the marriage the woman doesn't get
um does it become destitute right but
it's just become totally
subverted now whereby marriage only
favors the woman so from a
logical sense i can see why the people
from the red pill community will say why
should you do it in this environment
because what advantage it is to us men
which you know
the woman has everything to gain and the
mass everything to lose so i sympathized
it from that perspective but you know
what it is it's like when it comes to
that type of like oh a man with a man
meets a woman and like you know there
was just like a strong connection at the
time you're like well building report
from what you said about the whole or a
man there's a certain amount of time
like like from what i've from my
experience personally what i've noticed
is that
um when a man meets a woman we call it
the honeymoon stage right right which is
like all sunshine and rainbows
butterflies in your stomach you can't
wait to see her three months yeah
yeah exactly
it's the top coat so the way the way up
it's always
from what i've learned is three months
is three between three months and four
months four months stretching it right
yeah it's like those are like the golden
numbers no matter you could be in the
best relationship in your life but the
thing is when you get into a
relationship first right the first three
months to four months right yeah are the
get to knows you the higher how i used
to meet the family the um
the
learn what you like about what you like
and what you don't like the the what
sexual position you like from a man what
a sexual place you like from a woman
it's all that negative after those three
months it's really in a relationship
it's all about the communication because
after after that year it's what the man
has to offer the woman or what the woman
has to offer to man because that's when
you really got like look at it like look
i want to talk to that person
and know like oh there is an argument
let's see how we can solve it together
rather than like oh i'm right and you're
wrong
that's what after those three months
it's like it's really about
communication right
okay do you what are your what are your
opinions on like waiting until marriage
sex before marriage yeah yeah yeah um
that would definitely solve a lot of
problems
that was so
that would solve a lot of university
problems because because when people get
we would have sex back in the day yeah
sex before marriage that used to be a
very good that's a golden state and you
thought he was like set off for good
people to grow up and whatever now
because people are having casual sex and
there's nothing wrong with that but
because they haven't taken so much like
a lot along with that there's a lot of
wrong with that but i'm saying like
as long as it's consented right what i'm
saying is like as long as a person can
sense it right you could that's fine
it's casual sex
right but then the casual sex can lead
to oh unexpected pregnancies yeah so it
causes a lot of problems
and when you're in university and like
not even in high school like high school
is when you start getting sexually
active when you try to get you know try
some new things universities when you
actually like you have four years of
your best life you can be any like yeah
from i'm to quote a movie i'm not
remember what movie is but the quote is
basically
oh no it's from american pie i don't
remember which one an american pie does
the steven siffler
quoted
you can be whoever whatever you want to
be in college american term but like
you can be wherever you want to be you
don't have to be who you are you can be
whatever character you can be in
university right like a reset button for
you right that's what led into the whole
having a lot of sex and you know and
then that could potentially lead into a
lot of problems yeah right well did did
you and your wife like wait till you
were married or no yes my wife
beautifully was a virgin your wife was a
virgin
that's so cute
how old was she she was um 35 she was 35
year old oh my god i've never met you
sure
she grew up in a christian home so that
really helped as well yeah for me that
was one of the things that attracted me
to her because obviously
i'm quite strong in my faith i believe
that the man should take the lead and
obviously provide um provide for the
family spiritually emotionally and
physically right and when i met her she
said you know what i want men to lead
i'm more than happy to be a stay-at-home
wife i'm not career driven those things
just ticked my box and i said let's do
this
would you would you say your wife was
like submissive in like in that sense
the way you used the way you described
it
so what she did was she
empowered me to be to to walk in my
biblical masculinity to be the leader
she wants me to be so for example she'll
say to me you'll ask me a question from
the bible i was reading this could you
explain that to me that for me i felt
honoured by doing that as well and yes
because she was single for a while there
are a few issues that we clash but we're
both falling human beings but this is
where you've got to give her grace but
she's given me grace and she's enabled
me to lead the way i should do you see i
feel more masculine being married than i
was when i was single
wait so okay question yeah sure if if
you had if you had a girl that wasn't a
virgin would you wait with her
if she was like
i'm born again okay okay okay okay
because this is i think i think this is
one of the like big contentions that the
manosphere has yes with um with like
like with the church right
you have all these girls that are like
they've done their business all of a
sudden they've come to the lord i have
so much to say about that
so and so like on one hand i kind of see
both sides a little bit right because
girls it's like they're flooded with
attention from the time they're like yes
what fifteen fourteen so like who makes
the best decisions at fifteen fourteen
yeah especially like some girls like
don't have their parents around like
right some girls more than others right
now so i see one i see one at right wait
wait but then on the other hand these
guys are like well why would i wait when
you gave it to the last 20 guys for free
and i have to marry you so it's like i
always
i can totally see that yeah from a um
manusphere's point of view and there is
a slight skepticism because what happens
is i think this is the mistake that some
of these so-called born-again virgins do
yeah they think because you've been
forgiven of your sins doesn't mean
you're released from the consequences of
your sin right and that's the mistake
you see so what times what tends to
happen and i think it's a lack of
humility whereby let's say someone went
through their whole face right has come
to see the light they think that now i'm
a christian now i've been redeemed right
you should treat me as if i'm some
sort of virgin that's never been touched
i'm like it's like me going to prison
unless i i committed the hideous crime
right that's a prison for 20 years came
out and expect someone just to ex you
know a fellow
just because i'm a christian expect a
fellow girl to say oh i know you had
some sexual deviance in your past but
i'm just going to forgive you and just
let you go
there has to be some sort of humility
from my part right i think what these
born again virgins need to do is like
okay just because
i've taken a new leaf i've still got to
have some humility because there's going
to be a bit of skepticism right and
stuff like that now you know what i was
i was i was going to i was going to
actually building that onto two points
first point being this like
once like you've go through that let's
say the whole face and stuff like that
and i've known one person that's been
born again christian and stuff like that
right
and she's gone through
a lot of
dick um cap and stuff like that but
yeah when she went through the whole um
being born again virgin born again
christian and stuff like that right um
she had a boyfriend at the time right
okay and to put it in the second point
being is like if you're cool if you've
done what you have to do right and
you've done bad like you've been down in
the dumps and you did anything to
survive and whatever that's
understanding but that's what you're
gonna talk in your mic yeah we can get
like we can get past that but if you're
born again like whatever you go get
baptized and you're like oh i don't have
anything like that but you have a
boyfriend this is where this is where it
gets a bit like a bit more tricky
because
when you was doing all that stuff right
before that
you were just doing it for the fun of it
you was doing it to get by now that
you're born again and you're with a
boyfriend and now he's
been there done that i know you're
telling him
like oh i can't do this anymore because
i'm born again right now you're looking
like because the boyfriend is going to
have to look at you you're going to be
like are you serious because like are
you okay with your head like we've just
done this and now you're telling me we
can't do this anymore until marriage
right that just doesn't make any sense
right i guess in that situation what i
would say is that that relationship
would need to end absolutely
because like i say it goes to the
religious side you know there's a
scripture and new testament talks about
don't be unequally yoked with
unbelievers so if someone's claimed to
be born again and is still with a
non-believing boyfriend why are you
still with him yeah you're part of your
fruits are being born again so you're
going to cut relationships that are
toxic and that would be problematic yeah
but that's but that's when you're
looking at it from a perspective of like
he would look so let's say for example
they're together and they love each
other right yeah and then he he knows
that her positive and he's okay with she
knows he's past and he's okay with it
and now she's born again went to the
stuff like that and whatever
she knows about her and what she has
done
she can't do anymore yeah but this but
obviously in the case of like if he
loves her and she still loves him it's a
bit harder to like oh
we need to end this relationship because
you want something that i can't do yeah
but then it's like why did you get into
a relationship with me when you know
you're gonna but then it's the same
problem as there aren't enough men in
the church so i think that's really bad
advice that the church gives to be
honest
what bad advice in terms of so like
they'll say they equally yolk so you'll
see you'll see girls turn down perfectly
good men like my dad's not really
religious but like he acts like a
religious person my dad doesn't drink he
doesn't like he doesn't have social
media he's a really hard worker like and
if my mom turned him down because like
he wasn't equally i think that would be
a shame and i see it happen all the time
in the church where like perfectly good
men they turn down because they're not
equally old
or part of the church when there's like
i think there was like a dating event in
my church and it was like 85 women that
signed up yeah like that's that's crazy
there's a lack of men in churches but
this is where as the church we need to
cater it for men you know and stuff like
that and i agree but like we're here
yeah you know what i mean like that's
that's great for like the next 20 years
but the girls that are in church today
yeah that's not good advice yeah but the
problem is that there is there is an
ancient
wise man once said this to me if you
marry a child of the devil you have big
problems with your father-in-law so what
i'm just saying is that even if they do
bring and what what you
bet what you said between your parents
yeah that's more the exception than the
rule but the rule would be if they did
marry someone that was not a believer
long term that could bring some problem
because the problem is okay do we go to
church how do we discipline that kids
yeah i'm talking about the three r's
before you can start their relationship
you know what it is yeah like i've been
so i went to states right
um for a whole year and obviously our
one of our coaches that i i trained with
was
a religious man right and then i've been
to a church here now the thing is the
difference like there's a like
everyone's under apprehension that like
oh when you go to an american church
it's like oh you know all dancing and
singing and it is because i've been
there and i've done that like from
personal experience speaking i went to
there and i've seen people running down
the aisle catching the holy ghost i'm
seeing people
sweating while they're singing they're
dancing they're having like they're
letting their spirits out and stuff like
that and then when i go when i went back
here i went to a church just not not on
our on a weird like oh because obviously
i'm religious but like you know i don't
really go to church like that
but i one day just to kind of like see
the difference and it's like
i understand why people don't go to
church here like men i understand here
because when you go to church here it's
like there's one guy at the front
speaking
and the monastery
whereas when when you go to an american
church i've been yeah it's like there's
there is a pastor speaking but you have
the choir singing in the back you have
people chanting screaming like letting
their spirits but there's not positivity
out but there's not men in those
churches either
in the american churches there's not
there's there's not there's i've
definitely the thing is the difference
that's one that's why i'm saying the
difference is there i've seen more men
in the american church then rather than
here so i'm not saying i'm not saying
that obviously there's a lot more
but there's definitely more in an
american church rather than there is in
uh in the churches around here really
i've seen that from a personal
perspective because when i used to be
about i don't know 15 16 years old
before we used to have our practice we
used to have a church session there and
there was a lot like
a lot more women but it was just so
honestly
the service was boring i'm like and
that's like you know not against the god
but like it was just boring was it
christian or catholic i
wonder if you couldn't tell it's
probably catholic
ceremonies i honestly could not tell you
but it was just like even
even like i just thought christian
dating was so weird
i thought because like there is one
everyone's so involved by the way i did
meet my wife for a christian dating site
i'm sorry i'm sorry there's exceptions
but i think the majority it's weird like
i would agree with you because because
one of them like
one they all need to be involved like
why does everyone like i would see these
like people like they would want to talk
to the church leaders about who they
were interested in yeah and they're like
why
why do you need to involve yeah but the
whole point is and they make it they
make it so slow they like pray like yeah
but then again at the same time when
you're considering a relationship it's
something that you have to count the
cost it's not something oh i just met
some nice guy that looks nice and we
want to get married surely you should
have the wisdom of elders to sort of vet
things for you because when you're in
that in fact in fluctuation stage
you can miss red flags
you don't look at the intention behind
it so if i see if i was single and i saw
a girl and i think she's nice she's this
she's that someone could say but she's
got kids out with two different baby
mamas
baby dads yeah
do you that happened to me by the way
where but i did consider a
a a woman but she had two kids from two
separate dads and the guy said to me are
you sure you want to do that and that
made me pause a bit yeah that's the
whole point of something having that
counsel that's actually interesting
because i found that like the church is
very forgiving for women
like a lot like they'll kind of think a
lot of times they'll encourage the men
to like date a girl that has been ran
through or like has kids with other like
yeah i think what happens is i think
what should happen there should be
accounting of the course so
for example let's say for the sake of
this conversation adam likes becky okay
becky has like i said two kids from two
separate dads right one the church
elders the pastor would say i know
you're interested right could you handle
having a teenage stepdaughter okay step
son and could you handle the dynamics
with their biological father what
happens is if you want to install
discipline
as if the teenage daughter says to you
you're not my dad
and that could really bring that i think
so far there's accounting of the cost
and if he's happy to deal with it then
yeah don't get me wrong i like i agree
with you but like okay i went oh my god
i went to catholic school and they would
have chastity speakers come in okay have
you heard of christina and jason everett
no i've probably seen that but probably
not her name so basically like
and i tell the story all the time
because they they would come in right
and the girl would basically say she
would say like oh like in high school
like
she would make i was lost i lost myself
i emphasized with her like at a young
age you're given a lot of attention she
was a very attractive woman like okay
okay and um but
then like i found god and i like got my
husband right and i'm like and i
remember thinking because i just think
differently i'm like
so you're telling me you got ran through
and you still found your husband
and i'm like
is that how we do it yeah i think so
nowadays
sometimes with
american evangelicalism it's the
hollywood sort of rags to riches right i
went from i was this yeah and a happy
ending in reality most of the time
life's not like that no yeah
that's why i would agree with you on
that saying that story gives the
impression that oh so far i come to god
god will give me a husband and yeah and
i think and sometimes we have to
remember it's not always going to be a
happy ending sometimes and remember
marriage is not a right and so what we
have to tell some of our brothers and
sisters in the church it's not all right
jesus wasn't married you know and also
the impossible and because yeah they're
taking away the consequence and she gets
now she gets to make money off of this
story
i'm like that sounds great
this is the blueprint go ahead what it
is yeah this is this is another thing
it's like before marriage and stuff like
that right like you know yo yo if a girl
or any female is out prowling for a
husband right now before it was more or
less just like
like you like you said before the
podcast but it was like a range marriage
or stuff like that nowadays it's like oh
i'm gonna go to the club i'm gonna shake
my ass yeah stuff like that yeah but
this is and this is this is the this is
the this is the like
really really like [ __ ] up part right
it's like
if i'm going to a club and this has
happened like more times than i can
count right did you as like as a guy
right you go out look your voice calls
you and you're like let's go out and you
go out and you have a good time and you
obviously you go to the club obviously
you're expecting to you know meet a lady
or whatever you know whatever now when
the ladies go out they have a girls
night they're like oh blah blah blah
and when you are in the club in the time
like you find it and whatever and you
meet at the girl and stuff like that and
it's like you talk you talk you talk
and then obviously like you know that
the whole controversial thing like the
ugly friend always stops saying like oh
pushes her to the side but it's just
like it's so much harder now to be like
because if you don't know the person so
for example if i'm going out with just
the guys
and you let's say you locate a group of
girls and you're trying to let's let's
let's try and talk to them and stuff
like that if the girl group
or any of the girls in that group
[Music]
i don't really go out like that but like
i don't know i think
some i don't know i i i went to a pickup
event you know what i picked up it's not
a real event no no like a pick a bar so
it was like um i i'm i'm nosy right so i
went i went
i found out like pick up artist you know
what that is okay you know you know okay
okay so i went to this like pickup
artist event in ut or in um
vegas where basically all these guys
would pay like five grand i swear to god
i was like you want to make money
learning yeah you know it's actually
yeah
it was like 10-ish of them and like
basically what they would do is they
they have like five like three to
five-ish instructors you pay for your
own hotel too so there's like no cost
you just pay the instructors now five
times that's 50 grand three days no do
this map right this is i was like money
yeah i had me thinking i'm like can i
teach me how to get one
anyways though so um but i would
this is where the difference comes in
right
you're talking a lot like las vegas
nevada right yeah yeah i'm talking like
in uk yeah you go out to the club look
if you're going out to like a side
hustle club
but they they they
on the outskirts right right that's what
i've known right the most popular clubs
in in like shoreditch as well as like
studio
333
mother or something like that um we have
the bull pit and stuff like that these
are like the most popular high-end clubs
don't charge more to korea yeah yeah but
even then so like you have like some
high-end ladies that go in there you
dress up like they look good they look
dressed for the night you know what i
mean
and you as a guy
mentally you're like look i'm i've
located the person that i want to talk
to you yeah approach them yeah and like
girls like this is this is like the
trigger that like crushes every man you
have the courage after the whole night
no matter how much you had to drink yeah
drink bring builds confidence and yeah
that's a god given
you walk up to that girl and you you
know
drop a line on her like whatever it may
be like hi hello or drop like a cheesy
right right
the girl literally in that split moment
in a second mentally they're like i can
either crush this guy or i can like
entertain it for a little bit but this
is where the thing comes in because you
the girls that entertain it
potentially could just be like nah i'm
not gonna have sex with you right
but i would ex graciously accept that
all the free drinks that you're buying
me whereas if you just like i wouldn't
personally i wouldn't travel you crushed
my dreams without ever talking to you
because it takes me like a pretty
personal time yeah just my time but like
the girls that entertain it expecting
like a whole drink out of you but will
never have sex with you those are the
girls i was like like yo like
you can be born again you can be
whatever like i would i would not [ __ ]
well
i suppose she could give it to her she's
she is being
uh wise as a serpent well
yeah
you've never seen the tic tacs where
it's like after i get my drink and it's
the running
but
actually no recently no the truth be
told recently there was a there was a
tick tock that i've seen where the
basically so the ticker goes like this
it goes
the guy comes up to a girl and he goes
oh can i get you a drink
he goes no it's bad for my legs
why do they swell no they spread
that was the most like most recent one
and that got me thinking i was like
that's not flipping through no matter
what in what universe you live in that's
not really true it used to be like that
but it's not like that anymore because
the girl will you can they will
entertain you as much as she wants to
with no intention of having sex well
that's the one thing i learned from the
pickup event
this was so fun i had a great time i was
i felt like a dude because i was like
get her get her go go
no it was free because i i had the no i
mean i had the guy on my chair so i had
a boyfriend then so i had the guy on my
channel i just had to make good content
like a girl going to a pickup event
i had um it wasn't worth it i had to
blur so many faces it took too long too
long but but um i was like they had to
approach so many girls just to get like
laid basically and this was even the
instructors who were like in my opinion
like they're very very good looking so i
was like i could like i don't know some
of them had i would have doubts about
your boyfriend
um no no i didn't no i didn't do it like
you could have asked any of them i
didn't like energy why would i want to
sleep with a guy that just slept with
three girls in three days
that's like that's like a walking that's
like nowadays it's like that's not even
a normal question to us like cause girls
do crazy stuff but wow i told you guys
but so do you guys don't get me wrong so
do so do we but i'm saying
it's like a walking a cd i don't know no
thing like i swear the whole um it's
like scientifically it's like one in
four carries about an std and that's
from guys and females
yeah so that's that's a bit of like
that's why absence would be a good
option absolutely absence makes the
growth well here's the problem like
abstinence i think it's like a great
option i really do like i i want to do
it i know it's not easy no i know but
it's like at the same time like i don't
think it's really fair to guys to be
like oh be abstinence like after like
advocate yeah you know and i've told my
wife this that people should marry early
but on the caveat is that you have a
support network to help you if you got
married early yeah yeah so you had a um
you had your parents
your wife's parents yeah the church
community to help support you as you
got growing through that so you have a
bit what kevin samuel says yeah have our
kia marriage and i think that's the best
way to do it i the problem is nowadays
it's like i don't think marriage is like
i don't think people are going to get
married younger i agree i just don't i
think because of the event or the birth
control is the genes out of the bottle i
agree i have got my ideals but i have to
face reality
i agree with you and that's the thing
like i wish they kind of pushed age gap
dating a little like more when we were
younger yeah because like in college and
you date the guys in college they don't
want to get married
yeah and so it's like
that would have been like i wish i kind
of knew about that when i was a little
bit younger because i found that like
the older i date the more like serious
they are about me does that make sense
yeah yes but because i think we've had
our farm because what happens is i can
speak from experience obviously when i
was in my 20s yeah that was definitely
my whole face yeah but what happens is
you have an epiphany because you're
thinking i go to the club pick a girl up
bring her to my room do my business and
i want this girl out of my bed yeah you
can't do that indefinitely yeah it has
to be more to life than this yeah after
all even guys get tired of it yeah yeah
yeah well and it's like
i think most people want to spend their
life with somebody yeah we do they do
and most people want to get married yeah
but
especially guys deep down we want a
legacy
we want that that's big for us okay do
you think it's more a shortage of
husbands or a shortage of wives
what's the question in terms of the like
the dating like so the dating landscape
do you think it's a shortage of husbands
or a shortage of wives
and if you had to guess what percent of
men and women would you say are wife
material like and husband material today
the problem is
the problem is as human beings we're in
a fallen state so we need incentives to
behave okay the problem is society
doesn't give us incentives to behave
right like for example if you wanted to
have sex he needed to get married so the
man had to get his stuffed [ __ ] together
right yeah but now it's like i don't
need to do that
with the event or the burp pill yeah
it's like i can have my cake and eat at
the same time right yeah and if a woman
gets pregnant it's her body her choice
she can abort the baby she wants right
there's no incentive you see because
human beings need incentive to work like
for example if you were working in your
sales job would you do it without being
paid no of course you wouldn't the same
way that we need i think what's happened
we've lost shame as well it's like
yeah i think
[Music]
like single mom is like you know so it's
like a it's like a trophy i'm a single
parent right right
yes
i'm not thinking
look at the consequences and look at the
effects it has on your children and it's
selfish it's selfish to like put your
kids in that situ situation let's speak
let's be fair some of them it's not
their choice if circumstances happen
they're when they thought they were in a
committed relationship right but it's
your choice before you get married like
yeah no but building on that and then
stuff like that
i've i've heard this phrase like
more times than i can count now i've
used that phrase because i was stupid
and young and dumb right but i'm pretty
sure you've heard of the whole day no
shame in my game i'm pretty sure at
least one of you heard that phrase yeah
yeah and that phrase to me is like cool
that's understandable
cool you know you have no shame you do
what you got to do but then it's like
like you said oh you know
mm-hmm look how it's gonna or you okay
it can affect or might affect what you
your your future self might be because
like there's other people that be
thinking about there's no shame in my
game and they follow up with uh with
like oh let the future me handle that
but in the future you will look back on
what you just said and be like i was so
stupid exactly exactly exactly and
that's what happened especially in you
know in in some of our communities where
people were thinking why is there
generational poverty but when you've had
a kid
at 19 years old
what chance have you got in reality you
know and obviously the kid especially
was a boy he hasn't got a father figure
the father figure is is the first
prison not almost a prison cell but it's
the first disciplinary boundary so he
prevents him from going to uh
i mean i i actually wonder how i didn't
end up in a gang or in prison you know
and stuff like that because my dad
wasn't really around but i was no but
that's the but that's the but uh we're
looking back at like stereotypes that go
reach back as far as like
30 40 years because like if you're
looking at it for like okay american
wise we're looking at like
34 sorry not 34 like maybe 50 years ago
we're talking like let's say for example
a good example ice cubes uh when he was
growing up right he was growing up in a
rough neighborhood where police didn't
give a [ __ ] like a crap about the black
people right yeah and they just arrested
him like no no ursula but like they're
always always searched and whatever and
then when the black people became
officers they would show up for the
white crop that's what the whole um
that's the police after police came out
with the whole thing right and then when
they went to detroit i think it was
detroit when they did the concert and
they got arrested for the whole thing
because they sang the [ __ ] police
because they were like
mavericks they didn't give a crap about
what they said or because in in america
there is a whole thing of like freedom
of speech right so whatever i say you
can't use that against me because that's
what my opinion is back then they didn't
the police didn't give a [ __ ] now so
that's when it's like here
i can go to a police officer and tell
them you're a [ __ ] and they would they
would not
arrest me they would be like oh can you
calm that language now that's like the
fine line between different countries
and how they treat them like i remember
i think it was like fifa
not like the football world cup right in
russia and when english fans when they
won the like they went to the finals
those quarter finals they were jumping
under the police yeah
that's the difference in rights it's
like the russians they were just like
they would [ __ ] beat them with a cane
and throw them in jail for a couple of
nights you know that's where it's like
it's really there's a really fine line
between what you can do and what you can
say
they say it's a freedom of speech but is
it
well and here's the thing like even i
posted something what did i post oh i
said there should be shame in having an
only fans like why would you wife a girl
with an only fans like this is
controversial
i don't understand i think what's
happened is that people want to have
their cake and eat it so for example if
you want to have an only fans you have
the freedom to do it you just have to
freedom of the consequences of doing it
that's what i said i said i'm never
gonna like tell someone what to do but
like why do we like my issue is we're
lying to young girls you're lying to
girls that like between like 15 to like
20. right your brain's not fully
developed and they're given a lot of
attention early yeah right like earlier
than i would say any other generation
right so you can be 15. like i i have
friends that were underage and had nfl
players like sliding into their dms and
like suit like yeah yeah
yeah yeah like under it like they don't
care and this is the
so my problem is like they think so
sorry to interrupt you they think that
like oh my god like in their mind as a
young girl they're like oh my god like
this guy like let's see for example as a
girl you [ __ ] you admired this one
player right and that player slides
in your mind it's not like it's a bit
weird it's like oh my god like you know
well cause to me it's like because i've
had nba players like dm me but i'm like
i'm gonna be one of like 50 like why
would i entertain that
no no i'm serious like why would i i'm i
know that like well they're not gonna
take me seriously why would i entertain
that i'd be one of a million yeah it's
like they're copying
why do you think they've done that
though is it this one a
quick one or
you know what it is i feel like it's the
five minutes like not five minutes so
sorry correction because i was gonna say
five minutes of fame it's not that and
as a basketball player right so what
i've noticed is right
but she said
nfl is it nfl players or nba players uh
nba i mean it was it was like uh he he i
mean he wasn't a good nba player
it was like the bench but this is like
this is what i'm talking about that's
what i'm trying to say as a basketball
player right
in england
the girls is a little bit hard because
they don't really give a crap around
like basketball players ready more like
football players if you're a football
player or like a rapper right
right they're like they will drop their
panties in america on the other hand
it's like if you're a basketball player
no matter how [ __ ] you are
they get the whole sense of like this
kind of potential
potential actually when i roll out of
comments i've come that to find out to
be true because once when i went there
and i was doing prep it was a simple
thing of prep school right and i and
once i started getting my word out like
oh this guy's from a european standpoint
of you and i didn't really believe about
the whole like you know oh a european
has so much more potential of getting a
girl in the states than is
i've come back come back to they love
them
they do love that they love the accent
absolutely yeah and once i came back as
a basketball player i was in a prep
school that means i did not go to
college or anywhere else but in that
moment in time i had girls throwing
themselves at me purely for the fact
that i was a european in a different
country and doing prep school basketball
because they loved their boss whereas
when i came back here it's a whole
different story
like you're a basketball player no
basketball players in the car i always
say basketball players ruin lives
especially in the us like the college
teams
um okay really quick guys we got a super
chat um from ra
ra gein9 okay i'm sorry i'm sorry i'm
butchering your name i'm sorry feminism
is powered by electricity birth control
and lack of shame for degeneracy
and promiscuity and culture and religion
get rid of promiscuity gospel and bring
back the old school biblical gospel okay
he is a guy he must have been like in
his 30s with one wife and like at least
two kids that's the guy that texted that
right there yeah well like i said
someone else
that's oh i'm all for that look i'm 22
years old yeah and i truly believe that
look having a good
marriage and a good like
like mentality towards marriage is oh
i'm all for that that's and i'm saying
that being 22 years old
guy next time he's married you know i
mean like i i'm all fooled out but the
thing is like nowadays like if i was to
get a girl friend and i'm like look this
is the one for me and i'm proposed her
guys always look at the factors of like
now i can guarantee you
i want to say seven out of ten girls
don't know how to cook
don't know how to clean yeah don't know
how to take care of the household
because all they know is like yeah but
then at the same time though just to
give brace to them have they been taught
that
exactly but that's the worst part they
haven't that's all i think sometimes and
this is probably one of my few qualms i
have with kevin samuels whereby he goes
who taught you that
but i think they came from broken homes
so of course they're not going to be
told how to do that also i don't know a
single girl my age that has a cookbook i
mean i'm sorry i'm so tired of this
standard where kevin samuels was like do
you have a cookbook i'm like once
why why would i have a cookbook when i
have the internet like like i can't have
these old men telling telling me how to
cook when when i'm like okay one two
there's like do you have your own
original recipes why would i when i have
youtube yeah no i don't believe why
would i make this up no i don't believe
i don't believe in the whole having the
cook look a woman doesn't need to have a
cookbook in our day in society back then
maybe because before the social media
that's understandable she writes
something down the guy likes it he
writes it down but now we have the
internet like this like this is if
anything gonna be in my notes app
exactly
is that
you know with a woman you know make a
house a home for a man but i suppose the
responsibility for us men we've got to
create an environment for women to do
that you see because i think if a woman
feels safe
she will submit to a man naturally yeah
but we can't as men demand it so that
means like minding respect from you it's
because i'm not mad i think there's a
masculinity like a short like shortage
too yeah
a lot of guys are very feminine totally
totally nowadays and and like it's also
like a lot of guys i feel like i work
harder than
and like and i like i'm sorry guys but
some of those guys are simpsons
sorry i have to say this as a man i'm
sorry
you are similar perspective some of my
men are like ahabs
she was the husband of jezebel the bible
and that's what we are no no like no
no i i agree completely but like you
know what it is yeah as as hard it is
for some men to hear we as men yeah
majority of us
at one part of my life myself we are
absolute simps yeah right like and
that's like
girls some girls hands down
and the girls do you like it absolutely
go for those girls but the majority of
the girls
they like a simp once you're in a
relationship while you're not in a
relationship as funny as it sounds you
have to be a prick because like the
whole theory of the nice guy finishes
last year comes into such a major play
because of like the girl needs to feel
like you as a man
if you like get into an argument she
needs to feel like you will tell her sit
down and shut the [ __ ] up
and she would like she would much rather
be some girls would get turned on like
all jokes aside yeah no no all jokes
aside rather than like a girl guys like
always submitting to like oh yeah she
raises her voice and she's like i've had
this conversation with like girls before
we're like like you tell me
tell me i'm lying right now you know me
we're like why are we like like more
into them after we fight
there we go
that's very because essentially what it
comes down to a woman craves to be led
and if she doesn't feel respect she's
gonna cause drama you see so i agree
there has to be a but i suppose it has
to be a constructive way how to do it
you see so well we like a guy that
doesn't treat like that treats us like
we're human there's nothing worse yeah
so we don't like we don't want a guy
that's just mean to us all the time for
no reason but like we know we're full of
[ __ ] sometimes
you know when you cross the line when
you're trying to test the guy's waters
oh you start something up you think oh
it's not really hard so i'm gonna make
something up to say
you just you're yeah yeah yeah yeah i i
don't think it's conscious
it is because look you can you female
this one this is what i'm trying to say
but as a female right look you could
make a
an argument of nothing like you could
literally be like you pass the trash can
right and you look at it and it's like
it's full right
and you're like
can you take the trash out and you'll be
like no and you cause an argument and
once once the guy has had enough not
necessarily to a point where it's like
it's just enough it is just enough so
he's entertaining what you're trying to
say sometimes guys will be like chilled
like it's like you have to mother them
that's what i'm saying
there's like i'm not there
right that's the
when you're having a guy that's like
look i'm gonna tell you you tell him to
take the trash out and he doesn't and
he's acting childish he acts childish to
entertain what you're trying to say but
once you go beyond and you start
shouting and he tells you yo shut the
[ __ ] up
and you're [ __ ] you know it comes
down it comes down
it comes down to this it's timing so for
example a man's had the hardest days at
work yeah yeah he's literally worked all
his ass off for like 12 hours right when
he comes in
the first thing for the first 30 minutes
you've got to let the guy just
decompress decline yeah that's all the
time
we need to talk that's the worst things
that guys hate to hear been waiting all
day
long no no no no no no no no it's
brain is sort of like i've just been
there battling with my colleagues at
work i just need to come here to chill
right now
the wise woman once said this year once
your husband comes home let him rest for
like half an hour to an hour let him
play his games get out the system then
constructively bring out any issues that
you have breathe
if you do it straight away that's what's
crossed a fight
yeah so no not even that but like
relationship tip no exactly thank you
one look look
no you know what it is yeah
i worked in construction right i've had
i have a working instruction while i had
a girlfriend yeah the first thing right
and she she didn't live with me but she
normally stayed with me yeah and it was
a case of like
i come back home right the first the
last thing i want to do right now yeah
is talk yes like you know i mean like i
come back home the first thing i want to
do is i want to take my [ __ ] off i want
to chill yes i want to go take a shower
a long shower listen to my music play my
games whatever yeah and then she hits me
with the what the [ __ ] the last look
i've had to tell this girl to shut you
you know a number of times but then in
in doing so it led to like what i said
was like oh she was like damn like she
he put me in my place you know what i
mean no which was fun for a time for a
time and the equivalent i like to say is
this that it's like when the girl's on
her period
no it's not it's not on her period it's
like three days
before like two three i have to be
sensitive to what i say that she's going
to be you know i might we might just
start crying yeah
and i have to be sensitive towards that
in the same way we ask that once we've
come back from work that you be
sensitive that we are
states
in
a
just need time to chill
after we've done that then
he can upload what's going on right
constructively or we're going to react
because we're going to feel under attack
and i'm going to respond you're going to
respond you're going to start crying and
trust me as guys decide like emasculate
us
when you say something because what your
words have power because women have the
power of words
you could say something that could
destroy our soul and that destroys us
for the rest of the day but it's going
to work depressed no but but but this is
the difference between men and women
it's like
men like if it was a man and a man
argument right and it escalated and you
threw hands right
like as a man right like the way i was
raised up and the way i've had arguments
and fights before it was a case of like
we got drunk we had a good time
something goes wrong we go outside we
sort it out we shake hands afterwards we
go inside and we'll be
when it's between man and a woman is so
much different because the woman
takes advantage of the fact that like
you are fighting for your equal rights
yeah the way i see it right like right
now you fought for your eucharist and
you got them yeah i've seen everyone
with a sequel but there's still the
whole thing of like
if you hit a woman it's you're going to
jail well that's [ __ ] because
if she hits you hit her back
cut her back
she said she said it she said it not me
my stance on it is that you can restrain
a woman if she's holding a knife but you
should not you should but you shouldn't
hit she's holding a knife ducker decker
no no this is this is the this one's
gonna say it's just threatening physical
okay like fine i have one thing if she's
like hitting you whatever but if she's
threatening you with the knife
no no no
this is this is this was this this was
my point right so when a woman right
let's say we have an argument she throws
fists right or like you said has a knife
against you whatever it may be right
you as a man you know as a man as a
mammal you are stronger right
so you don't necessarily need to hit her
you just need to put her in a position
where like wrestle her down like
she throws a hand at you you catch that
hand and you pull attack
but
i can't lie to you it turns into a whole
like damn like like he really did that
like you know they get like as funny as
it sounds they get turned on by that
moment because you let her know that no
matter what you do yeah you will always
if i'm wrong on this is that if they see
that they see that's a protector that's
the beast that i found yeah yeah like
i want that beast to come yeah
it's like they call it the dark triad
traits where it's like there's certain
the same traits that save the title
um okay wait so question question for
you so what's your beef with rolo he's
got beef with rolo tomasi yeah he
doesn't i think in his age
at his stage master is one of the main
influence in the manusphere my issue
with him is that
he seems to identify problems but
doesn't give constructive solutions and
that's one thing that's a uh
um
he kind of does he kind of does though
he says muscles like gain like he says
money must like if you want to increase
your statuses
money muscle
this is where you have to be
intellectually honest i can agree when
you can dissect the problem with a lot
of modern day women these days and you
have to be
guys need to be careful not to be
finesse i agree with that yeah but at
some point you need to graduate from
that right
there's a biblical um principle that
says you've got to leave milk and go on
to solid foods because right now i think
he's just feeding these young men milk
milk milk but women are wretched women
like this women like that but after like
i said okay once you find one this is
how you but you know what it is i feel
like he hasn't found the right one
though no he's not his marriage he's
been married for 20 years he loves him
no no no no no no this is like this is
what he says though like like rollo is
just a stats guy like i really disagree
with you when you say that he's like
pushing that women or trash whatever
rolo reads the numbers and like for
example one of the numbers is if your
wife out earns you there's an eighty
percent chance she'll leave okay so i
agree with him yeah yeah yeah the
dynamics will be
kind of screwed a bit yeah right and so
so
like i just think he he's someone who
analyzes data yeah and that's that's
what he does yeah so that's what he says
like we're bored as human beings but
more than just data
but i think but i think his whole point
is like there's a million channels
talking about men's self-improvement
solutions without like there's so many
people doing the fresh and fit do that
there's so many people that do it off of
his work his job is like he wants to
he wants to analyze the data like he's
just a numbers guy okay and so it's like
when you're talking about the numbers
that's an aspect but obviously i think
this has to be a point where but it has
to be a graduation but i suppose he
could argue my specialty is this yeah
yeah you want um
you know how to be a man how to be a
faithful husband go to a so-and-so
person so i see your point so i
conceived he said
he says rolo doesn't give solutions he
gives you the tools to solve your
problems so like for example like you
met your wife at 35 right she was 35 so
like one of the things is like when she
met you she had to see you as like the
best that she could do
and she probably did but like part of
that was her age right yeah right yeah
but like if we're talking numbers right
like you know the whole
this was mentioned at the start right
the whole um idea of if we're in a
relationship right it doesn't have to be
a marriage but a relationship right
i personally strongly believe right
that
a relationship no matter how funny or
whatever it's got to be 50 50. as funny
as it sounds right as fun as cliche
maybe right if someone is putting in 51
percent
into the relationship and the other
one's putting 49. it would be 50 50 like
money-wise no no no no 50-50 in general
like if i'm like if i'm going into the
relationship right or with a clear mind
of like i want to be with this person
right the same has to come from him or
her oh no no no no no i was i would
rephrase i will rephrase that i think
both parties need to live up to their
responsibilities right yeah yeah
yeah yeah because i think if you say 50
50 i'm gonna do this if you do that you
know as a man i'm meant to love my wife
no matter how she treats me yeah
unconditional love there's no there's no
condition to say okay i'm not going to
provide for her because you didn't okay
question question
okay
so okay before i ask this question i'm
going to read super chats because i've
had a group will come in do it
okay so so so the next super chat
is d oh gosh you guys can you guys have
easier names doing jose tx sarah de
silva good luck to the hammers hammers
fans tomorrow ynwa gonna
um captain cisco i want i want to marry
pearly uh thank you
lies lies
pipe down
all right blue pill unplugged x came
with me at me with a knife i called the
cops they told me if i hit her or even
if she had bruises i'd be in jail the
only thing men can do is leave
that's ass
that's [ __ ] if pearl made the laws i
would say you can hit a girl that comes
at you with a knife yeah that's what you
call make the loose i don't know i'm not
in charge here
i'm not i'm not okay like i think it's
one thing if she's like just like
hitting you yeah but if she's coming at
you with the full-on i would deck her no
i think no
you know whatever that means that's
funny i would love to see that i would
honestly love to see you specifically
deck up a person if it comes out with a
knife
okay so my question you said
unconditional love that's the biblical
standard that's the love that i've
i'm supposed to have for her because in
in the the new testament was written in
greek and the word translated as love as
as as described in new testament it's
agape that god plays the love that god
has for us so it's not based on what i
can do
so you have another love called a fella
which is like uh if you love me i love
you back and you have the other one
that's you know called eros which is the
sexual love right shakespeare
shakespeare done a whole a play about it
like when he was alive
well it was called othello
but it was kind of like bass basing
um love on a mask type thing because um
i don't know if you haven't you've seen
a fellow or anything like that
yeah so basically it was a lot of like
um
uh what was the thing was the phrase
called um
not necessarily misunderstanding but
like misleading something because like
one person says one thing does another
and there was a lot of that throughout
the other play towards the end it was
like
obviously love prevailed
but
in
the process that led to that was it was
horrific like you should really like
anyone that hasn't seen othello yeah
shakespeare
i recommend you actually definitely
checking them out and watching the movie
on i think it's on youtube if not if not
on youtube just check them out
on the shakespeare globe okay definitely
one of those things that you definitely
have a question
question so if she gained yeah 150
pounds yes i'm out
you staying yeah of course i am oh my
gosh for real yeah definitely oh my god
when you make your vows you say for
ritual for pour off or better for worse
she don't put a condition if she gets
fat i can leave
you can't tell a woman she can't go into
the gym you don't give up on something
like that you have to work on it you see
so no but if you don't know that this
this is the difference if i if i'm
married
and i've been married lester for example
happily for 20 years long time right
and let's say you're going into your 40s
right and she lets her herself go a
little bit yeah i can't like look i've
been happy really married for 20 years i
can't then go and be like well i'm not
i'm not really let's go to the gym you
know like well i'm not really talking
about that what i see is i see girls get
a ring and just completely let
themselves go
and that's what that's what i'm
advocating that's what i'm gonna say
leave the whales i'm not talking about
like women that are struggling with it
and trying i'm talking about girls like
get a ring yeah and say you know what
yeah it's it's time to just look i do
believe that i would say this though
there is a responsibility on both
parties to keep themselves attracted to
one another right yeah i think if you
let yourself
what you're doing you're inviting
temptations to happen
so i think
for the sake of the marriage it's good
that i stay
healthy and fit and she stays healthy
and fit at the same time but also i have
to remember
a woman's metabolism is different from a
man's metabolism so women's easy for
women to gain weight as you can testify
that it is for a guy so there has to be
that as well so i think it's something
that you can negotiate but i definitely
even if she gained another 300 pounds
300 you'd stay whoa
pause pause pause i'm sorry i'm sorry
listen listen no no no there's no
there's no remember there's no room
let's listen look
i can look if i'm married right and i
have look there is obviously a certain
pathway that you can both go to because
obviously like you said there's man's
metabolism is different to a woman's
right that's understandable right but
listen if i'm writing my vows no matter
how but look we've been married for so
excellent amount of years right and
after a certain time it is harder
because obviously as a as a human being
your body gets older your knees get
weaker your body it doesn't respond the
same way you used to be but that doesn't
give you like noise like all right but
like it does it just shows kind of like
yeah but you're creative i'm still
trying to be a target but as as but
again it's um it's a it's on me to
create the environment that she wants to
lose it so for example if that means
paying for a personal trainer
some girls are lazy like i have friends
that like i've known for a long time
yeah they've been they've just been lazy
they were lazy
they were lazy then they're lazy now now
there's more like consequence they're
getting older they've had these bad
habits for like before they were hot
yeah scientifically sorry sorry
scientific sorry sorry no no i'm
apologizing no no no you know i'm not
i'm not trying to stop scientifically
proven it takes a person or a female or
a male 28 days to 31 days to break out
of a bad habit carry on
so but that's what i'm talking about
like i'm not talking about girls that
are struggling or whatever like some
girls are just lazy
so even like biblically yeah but that's
not that's not gross to end the marriage
i think it is i think
no wonder there's so many divorces these
days i i'm trying to end it i'm trying
to end the trend here no that's not true
leaves and the women are more overweight
so the men aren't leaving they're over
there
they're they're not leaving the whale
but
what i'm just saying is that that won't
be of course for me to um 300 oh come on
400.
see my
my view on it is not necessarily what i
want is what what's biblically ascribed
to me
there has to be something against
gaining three hundred four hundred
pounds in the bible i don't know there
is there is no
yeah but
there is a scripture against gluttony
eating too much yeah that is again so
she will be in sin for eating too much
to gain that sort of weight so yeah
we need to change that leave the whales
no
no no no no no no no but the thing is
okay
no but the thing is if you're looking at
it from a fat
correction if you're looking from a
person that's like overweight right look
i've always been like this look if
a person's if a person has a certain
mentality right if i'm overweight right
but i'm happy
why why does anyone else have a right to
come on to me and tell me listen you're
overweight because in my mentality look
if i'm fat and i'm doing this right but
i'm happy while i'm doing this why the
hell does anyone else have the right i
agree with you i just think most fat
people aren't happy and i've had guys
i've had guys tell me that they won't
date overweight women but it's not
because of
dog um but they love the dog we love
them
like i've had guys tell me they won't
date overweight women but it's not
because they're not attracted to them
it's because they're so insecure
and they can scream oh i'm so confident
all day but i don't believe you okay
look i can ask you a question yeah so
this is a controversial question right
and i've i've seen this on youtube
asking people
how would you feel look if i asked you
like this right now who would you date a
guy with a six-pack or a guy with a dead
body
um are they the equal in every other way
no no but you just you know it's it's
not it's not a choice just literally one
or the other six pack exactly
yeah
everything else is equal like if they're
the same person one is a six wait why
would you not pay but most people
nowadays like what from what i've seen
on youtube specifically it's like out
there the guy with the girls because
he's chubby
they might say that but the numbers like
don't except the numbers don't happen
yeah because you can you have women's
selecting on dating apps and like they
select a very small percentage of men so
they might say oh we love the dad bobs
they don't really they don't they don't
know
they don't really absolutely not no it's
that's cat i think girls like accept it
right the same way guys accept
overweight
there was one comedian from um sorry uh
i think it was like the over the night
school the female um what's her name so
it was kevin hart and it was the uh-huh
i want any female comedians
i forgot her name but basically look if
you watch night school guys yeah there
was one kevin hart and it was the female
teacher who was the comedian
who was like
a lesbian and all that stuff but she
always picked like dad birds or whatever
and it was it was hilarious but like
like like she said um
it's scientifically not not not accurate
because like what they say and what they
do is two different things if you guys
want me oh yeah like and yeah that's
true girls because girls say one thing
and do the other yeah
because i don't even think girls like we
even know what we like but that's
because like i mean i'm a little more
aware because i'm in this space right
but guys will say things and at first
when i heard them i was like oh that's
not true but then you you sit back and
you like think about it a little bit
like like the even the guy like what you
were saying earlier when you're like a
guy that like like tells you to shut the
f up like you you're kind of attracted
to that and when i first heard stuff
like that i was like oh no or not
until you experience it
this is sorry this is a bit off topic
right okay but
what do you want to eat
just that itself like what i like to eat
no no no no like you it's this is like a
bin and you know as a guy like if you
ask yo oh babe i'm gonna order some food
what do you what do you want to eat what
what why is it so hard for as a female
why is it so hard for you to pick
because you always respond to because
women oh women pick whatever you want
and then we list off like a hundred
different places because women are
attracted to leadership yep so that's
why because you're you'd be like you're
asking us to lead so we're attracting
the leadership
because we leave you're like oh i don't
want this i don't know but it's like i
worked in sales so it's kind of like so
i kind of understand like
like it was
you're a horrible sales person if you
come in and ask like the customer what
they want instead of saying hey i know
you you like this and you like this
which one would you rather choose like
if you're going to bring a girl with
like choices you know what i'm saying
but or if uh if you come in as a
salesperson and you know them really
well and you're like hey i know your
business has this problem that problem
that problem this would be the product
to fix like that's better than like
coming to the customer and it's kind of
the same it's similar yeah and like and
as as a guy i'm not saying
your locals sorry if uk term you're
locals like because i work in
hospitality business our bartender right
and uh if i see a new person obviously i
don't know what they're like if i knew
if i see a regular face it's like oh
this guy's gonna have a yeah a pint or a
cocktail you know it's just like knowing
it's knowing your uh yeah
and that's and that's what girls but we
don't really know
that's what we want you know what i mean
that's what we need to lead but
effectively you see so okay there is
another super chat yes
okay um
raw guy and guys guys just see you now
guys guys there is gonna be a whole new
studio update we got a really big
donation that came in this week yeah
we're gonna be there's like a whole
studio revamp and i'm trying to raise a
little bit more money okay because i
want to get some like nice couches in
here and a wooden table and a wooden
yeah like get rid of the glass
everyone hates the glass no i love the
gloves but
um so all of your donations i'm not even
keeping money at this point right now
it's all being reinvested into the
channel so every donation helps i
basically have six months to get this
off the ground and profitable in order
for she leaves university yeah yeah so
so basically if you guys enjoy the
content and you want us to keep doing it
it's really important that you send
super chats so i really appreciate the
guys that do so ra
gynemai something sorry i'm sorry i
never get your names um biblical god
will ultimately push us for not
respecting him and his commandments love
is not unconditional respect must be
paid up for love to come down goes the
same with husband and wife men think of
yourself as the wife of god what do you
think of that yeah i think that's spot
on but what if the woman loses respect
after she gets the rank she's like i got
it
i've still got to love her even despite
because you see why the issue is this is
this is the mistake
with
i think our english translation yeah
yeah okay yeah this is a
misunderstanding i think our english
translation because obviously
the new testament was written in greek
okay and the love and the word that's
translated love okay in greek is called
agape okay agape is the highest form of
love it's a sacrificial love the closest
one is a what a mother has for a child
okay that's the love i've meant to have
for my wife it's the same love that god
has for for us because of god do you
think there's no situation where you can
leave no none no no really so okay what
if what if i get married okay yeah my
dude is sleeping around with the whole
town yeah brings home another kid yeah
another std yeah blah blah blah i can't
leave i think you can separate okay
until you repent before you can come
back together oh my gosh
people keep people don't change i i
don't think very well
i agree with you i think it comes down
to the issue of divorce and remarriage
obviously i take the
quite hard score uh school stance that
you know once you're married you once
your marriage you can't you can get
divorced but you can't get remarried
until that first spouse is still living
if that first spouse is still living you
can't get remarried so it's only two
days apart so if they take a hardcore
stance on it okay wait what do you think
so do you think born again virgins
should make the new guys wait what do
you think
is the new guy christian himself um
give me one guy yes one guy now
in all honesty if they said that the
chris they should obviously only um go
for someone that's that is christian so
that can that can simplify but there's
not enough so but there's not enough
christian guys supply and demand they're
not there then you can't you can't say
like change the church
obviously
the scripture doesn't promise every
woman is going to get married or every
man's going to get oh so she should just
be alone forever but that isn't that
unbiblical because then you're not
building families and like creating the
next challenge it's not guaranteed that
everyone should we could be married
right we'll get married right there are
going to be some what we call eunuchs oh
for sure for sure
that their focus is totally to god oh
and there are some people that are gone
they should just be celibate forever
it sounds like church nonsense i'm going
to be honest with you this sounds like
like i'm sorry i'm just you're telling
me that like the best option if a girl's
well
as well okay okay but if a girl's a
born-again virgin right
okay and she can't find a guy to wait
till she's married yeah you're telling
me her best option is to be alone
forever that's that's more because she's
that's more because she's looking you
you when you become a christian you're
not looking at this like you're looking
at the next so your main aim is not on
this life yeah but you don't think it
would be
like i think it'd be more fulfilled to
have like kids
and like because you're not supposed to
be alone like that's not how we were
creating you have to remember this
though kids are not a right they're a
privilege right so you know so you can't
say god i have a right to a kidnapping
you don't right you know you have a
right to judgment right well i'm not
saying well i'm not saying okay what
i'm not saying that everyone has a right
to kids but what i'm saying is i think
what you're saying as a society is
impractical
i think that like there's so many 35
year old single moms there's so much
like
there's so many single single child so
what's happening so i just i don't think
the solution for that that cohort of
people right yeah is gonna be to wait
for the christian men that don't exist
tell them right but like we're talking
about how society is known
we can talk about how like it can be in
the future but like it just doesn't seem
like an optimal solution i think the
optimal solution is a long-term solution
because what needs to happen is is that
there is a saying biblical center has
don't put new wine into old wine skins
have you heard of that same before no so
literally what has happened in biblical
times
they used to have the
pit the goat's um stomach was used as a
wine skin that's where they'll pour the
wine
yeah so if you put new wine into a new
wine skin it will hold if it's used up
again and you put wine again it will
burst up so what's happened is that we
have sown the seed of chaos since the
since the sexual revolution okay and
we're looking at the fruits of it right
now yeah so what needs to happen now is
that we need to sort the seeds for the
next generation so it could be and this
may sound a little bit unfair
some people have just it's just too late
for certain certain people for the
generation
so if
we're trying to look it's a bit like
kevin simon this is what i would agree
with kevin samuels when people call up
to him and says but i'm a single mom how
am i going to get married who's going to
marry me and kevin samuels and this is
what i agree with him on is that tough
decision and unfortunately some people
are in that situation right so i'm just
thinking about a long-term solution is
that we need you to start do you think
that's going gonna happen though
well i've not believe it or not there is
part of me that thinks that something
will happen because you have to remember
that the world has has cycles you see
yeah if we're too prudent
and too strict what happened is that a
rebellion will happen and have the
sexual revolution yeah yeah so what's
happening now we're too loose now yeah
everyone wants to go back to a
conservative model do they you see high
schoolers these days no because
they see the rise of feminism and right
they're sick and tired of this they
don't really go back to it correct
things so that's what will happen so my
my hope is that because of the chaos
that we're in
it will kind of force us you know i'm
going to go back to our traditional
lifestyle
i would hope so but i don't see the
trends going that way because if you
look at if you look at the data it's
like a smaller and smaller percent
percentage of men are having sex with
more and more girls yeah and body counts
are going up up up yeah i i would hope
that happens i don't see it i was gonna
say i think it might do because i think
people will become disillusioned i think
right now as you as the internet is
opening up yeah we've seen a lot of
professional women who are literally got
their stuff together but they're in
their late 30s i think i have no man i
have to freeze my hands because you know
what is here the one one great actual
example right that i've actually from
what you just guys told me about is um a
youtuber right influencer named by the
name of taylor alicia right
so
i used to watch her when i was like
but i still watch her to this day but
like when i was watching she was a bit
younger
so basically she used to date a youtuber
by the name of time of tanner fox i
don't know if you've heard about him or
anything like that
so they dated they didn't work counselor
and she and then she went through the
whole i'm born again christian right
she posted a video of her getting
baptized and stuff like that right and
then up until recently and by recently i
mean like literally two days ago
i was scrolling through the tick tock
and instagram and then i also followed
her and stuff and she was like
going through a bit of like one of those
things where it's like i'm pretty sure
every born-again christian went through
a case of like
i'm trying to find not necessarily a
husband but i'm trying to find a person
to be like
my piece essentially right yeah and
in her like hello little video she she
goes and talks about it like look i've
i've done this about two years ago i by
two years ago meaning i've been baptized
for two years
it's not been the greatest time but it
hasn't been the worst time because of
you know in my eyes i'm doing better for
the gods
in front of god's eyes but in doing so
i'm not finding the whole man and you
know and stuff like that and what can
you guys suggest and stuff like that
and it's like
it's your life it's your choice but for
me personally if you're willing to go
down the path of
you doing the whole i'm being
born as a
new thingy there is limitations that you
have to that you have to abide by
because if you are born again christian
you have to obviously there's certain
principles you live by exactly so you
have to go uh all up against all that
she definitely had sex before that like
yeah it's a goddamn right
but it's a case of like oh i now can't
have sex before marriage i now can't do
this i can't now
um find uh just a random person and just
like you know yeah but it's gotta be
yeah but it has to be structured it's
not that you can't have sex you can't
have sex in the right context and the
right context is marriage so she is so
called a born again virgin what needs to
sorry what needs to happen
what needs to happen is that she needs
to go to her
spiritual elders
and say to her look you know i'm this
i'm looking for i want to get married do
you have any recommendations for me what
should happens it's the pastor
the church should have a singles
ministry whereby they're cultivating
that as well matchmaking each other so
they can vet each other for both they do
but it's just all women that's the
problem but that's what i say but i
think we've got to get like i said this
is where that's job as men we need to
get more men in the church
and make the gospel more manly what the
problem is is that the church doesn't
emphasize jesus's
masculine qualities because i've always
said this jesus is the epiphany alpha
male he actually identifies himself as
alpha yeah in the book of revelations
but and the other problem is like the
like women
are kind of it's like the church is
becoming more feminized like women are
this is the one thing about catholics
they do not let women in leadership yeah
i like it i like people they do
exactly
old school and that was a feminism
no i i i understand it because when you
get like this is coming from someone
like i actually i want to run for an
office one day but like i i i really do
um like not what office it can't be this
one no no no no that's a senator maybe a
lot of people i don't know this like
this would be that's like my last career
like i want to do that in my 40s 50s i
don't know older
but like i think how do i put this like
the more women in general that get into
leadership the more it's like communal
the less accountability there is for
women and that's the biggest thing it's
like i think men are like sick like
they're kind of rolling their eyes at
these women who aren't being held
accountable like because there's no one
in the church saying look it it might be
over for you
because of the choices you made yeah i
think there needs to be honesty with it
as well
these pastors and their desperation to
not just discourage we give them false
hope i feel like i'll give them a
realistic hope well that's that's
something like god is realistic hope
though well that is religious if you've
had the past it's the chances are and if
you've got um obviously kids out of
wedlock you may not get remarried again
right but you got to see that your
reward is not in this life it's not
sorry let me remember the question what
is the
what is wrong with that in a sense of
like right now because back then
having a children at woodlock you would
obviously not remarry but now and
specifically like nowadays i mean come
on this if there's no father figure in
the home there's course especially if
there's if it's if it's a boy he needs
his father you know in the house to
[Music]
before i was born yeah so i didn't have
a father figure i've only had women
around me yeah so it's like for me i can
you can use me as a perfect example yeah
i grew up with women in my house yeah
and i've turned out okay yeah but at
some point though you because you're six
foot three four mm-hmm or five six six
months six months you're off yeah
you were 12 years old you were probably
taller than your parents your mom no
actually i wasn't i've got my girls per
late for two months yeah yeah but
sometimes you know at some point when
you're a teenager there's no way that a
a mum can physically hold you absolutely
the father figure in the home well and
like statistically you're at such a
disadvantage yeah like you're at
basically every disadvantage and like
even as someone like wouldn't you have
preferred to have like a father
absolutely yeah
no absolutely of course because yeah
like i've always liked i've seen
pictures of my dad yeah i've obviously
got you know the emotions and stuff like
that right i've gotten past that phrasal
verb right i've seen like my um my
grandma from my dad's side showing me
all the pictures of like i've gotten
past the whole of like crying and like
yeah yeah i've seen him i was like
listen look this is the man that
actually gave you know yeah produced me
type thing in it yeah but i've never
been like the guy to like oh like off
like i don't know where my place in the
park or in the world is because i don't
have a father yeah because there's
there's other people so like my mom's
sister's husband that stepped in yeah my
father but you have masculine energy
yeah yeah yeah so i'm not saying it has
to be a physical father but there has to
be a masculine role model right that can
teach you the basics like how to
do a tie how to change a tyre how to do
the handy work in around the home i
can't like yeah they should be there
yeah they fully do that
okay um guys we have another super chat
from the actual the actual king smith
awesome channel here's a little bit to
the pot keep the content and collabs
coming king from the dating game channel
thank you i appreciate it
guys
these super chats for real help so much
and if you can't super chat guys like
the video
like the video almost does the super
chat closely it's uh anywhere this the
lowest one is two dollars and the
biggest one i've ever got is like 300
something like that so it depends hey
keep the stupid chats coming though
keep them coming guys for real guys like
they really help the channel and you're
gonna see you're gonna see a big a big
up in the studio soon so i'm probably
gonna be helping build that here
okay um
so let me go back to some of the
questions that i brought um
okay
the church and dating oh do you think so
you're christian right you think
christians are all up in each other's
business i feel like christian this is
why
there's pros and cons i've done catholic
and i've done christians right
catholics i love yeah every sunday it's
like once a week it's horrible 45
minutes i'm not gonna lie to you guys we
gotta up the service like it's i'm so
bored the whole time yeah um and so for
that reason i prefer christian mass
but but what i liked about catholics is
they just kind of mind their own
business yeah my last christian church i
i started dating a guy right and he
wasn't christian
and i got so many calls from these
people i barely knew i'm like who
could you guys like leave me alone but
they had some good intention though they
might because they realize that
sometimes romantic relationships can
definitely cause an asterisk effect
between your relationship with god
that's what they're
looking at their their logic behind i'm
not saying you need to agree with it but
i'm just saying that's their logic i
don't understand what they're working
from i understand that yeah i get i
understood the intention
but i just feel like i'm a ground-ass
woman
chill
and
i'll get i'll get this i'll get this
advice from my parents and the people
that actually know me
what i think what should happen is that
this is what we think is good but at the
end of the day it's your choice you're
going to make that decision anyway
because they can't police you 24 7.
right but they have to be intellectually
honest that they say i don't think this
will be good for you right spiritually
right and but
that's what i like about catholics
though they just kind of they're chill
yeah but they don't think at the same
time though it's christian
this is the question i posed to you okay
what's the number one
qualm people have for christians
what do they say high with christians
judgmental yeah what's the other one
just throw it in there um what's the
other one that they're i'd say
judgmental is the biggest one not
hypocritical oh hypocritically we don't
live up to us our ideals oh yeah yeah
yeah the same way the reason why that
way is because obviously if you're a
christian
it implies that you're going to live
under a certain moral code right yes so
and there is a
thing that has okay if you're a
christian and you claim to follow christ
right and you do xyz right there has to
be okay you're not following the program
right it's a bit like if i'm in the army
right and i don't follow what my
sergeant says well but i'm like you got
you ladies are single
and so it's like
i don't really see you having better
results so why would i take advice from
you and not my parents yeah and so yeah
but this is what comes down to it is
it's a you say it's a holistic uh
problem right whereby we need to get
more men to church right i agree with
that and it's the same thing as like
then i was like okay do i wanna
there's like okay and the church i was
in there was maybe like two or three
guys that i would consider like i was
attracted because one there's a lot of
beta guys in the church a lot of
feminine guys yeah like i would never
give the time a day i'm sorry um and
then two there's like one or two guys
but like there's like
women lined up for those guys because
they're like one of the few good looking
guys in the church
i don't want to why don't i just date
someone outside of the church yeah but
the problem is that you have the
achilles heel of potentially you know if
you go serious and
if you're very spiritual and he's not
yeah and you have kids together yeah
it doesn't but i think that's knowing
the guy's character and i think a lot of
guys aren't in the church but would be
fine with like a woman like raising
their kids in the church because i
possibly i'm not saying it wouldn't work
but potentially it's a lot of banana
skin i'm just saying from you know what
it is i feel like i feel like
if if you're a female in a church like
um
and this is me quoting
um i don't know a second joyful joyful
noise right yeah um one of the scenes
was like a guy comes in completely out
of the church and sees one of the
females singing in the joyful noise
right she loves her and whatever i feel
like
if you're a woman of you know belief and
god and stuff like that right
you have a lot to offer yeah and if a
guy like necessarily don't necessarily
like a guy from church like he said yeah
but a guy outside of church right he
meets you and you fall in love with him
right out of just the pure bleeding like
you say you will still as a woman would
have more to offer because you went to
church like nicely but you know what i
mean yeah and then the guy would
obviously treat you like as a princess
or whatever like right we'll get
together
but obviously
it would be like uh like a respectable
boundaries between that that's why i
mean but my argument with that would be
that can work but i've just i'm saying
it from a statistical perspective and
you've definitely you've been good at
this yeah that's more the exception than
the rule most times if those
relationships do happen it does affect
the christian woman and she'll be like
why did i marry this guy
for love you're married for love
yeah but here's here's like what i
disagree with though like the numbers
just don't add up to what you're saying
there are not enough men in the church
so so i think what you're saying is like
idealistic
ideally sure like of course but like it
when there's not enough men what else
are the girls supposed to do so
yeah
just because i have a it's like me
saying
oh there's a problem with um
um let's say racism in our society so
the solution is joint black class matter
so you know i mean yeah yeah there are
nuanced discussions with it as well so
what is your thingy of like you know um
building on that thing yeah you said
like oh black lives matter
but you remember the there was like a
little segment and this is coming from
like five minutes of fame type segment
in it yeah all lives matter yeah i feel
like that's [ __ ] i think it's a bit
like saying i i've created a a charity
for cancer but someone says but also
aids yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
thank you i think it's i think it's yes
i think it's said in a i uh
initially i would have taken all lives
matter but to someone actually explained
use the ideology so
like if you put it if you put it to
perspective of like
if someone comes up on the screen right
we've never heard it before and he goes
oh lives matter oh life's not just to
begin with right
i feel like we just had a smooth ride
yeah whereas he said black lives matter
right mm-hmm right yeah
and then he goes on like not necessarily
him but like another person goes but
then at the end of the day all lives
matter
that's like that's a bit like sometimes
you can be like it's a bit like you know
like i said i started charity but i said
what about age two it seems insensitive
yeah you can't you can't slay every
dragon you can only slay one dragon at a
time so
okay guys there's another super chat
thank you thank you thank you raw gynema
may i'm sorry i'm so sorry i know can i
call you raw
oh no just call him
okay um let's go the thing i love about
hos
is they never truly change just present
their situation and risks and their
mindset the bad boy can always oh hoes
the thing i love about hoes is that they
never truly change just present their
situation and risks and their mindset
the bad boy can always get it
never change ladies us
fellas only need time to get you
oh yeah
i think they're saying hoes don't change
like once a whole always a hug what you
think about that
one's a whole one
way one one define a hoe okay two once a
whole always a hoe so which one does it
go first what define a hull
you speak with someone that's
promiscuous that's um you know
like has the um
that that does do what we call love
legs open very
easy okay legs legs open very easy yeah
i'll agree to that legs open very easy
okay okay now two once a whole always a
hoe yes or no okay have you heard of the
term what proverb means
i would not say that i have okay
probably means it's a statement that's
gen it's genuinely true but not always
true
that's what i would say it is okay yeah
what about you
from my from before
i'll put it to this way i'll give you
two points from from uh
myself
seventh when i was 17
once a whole always well i'd probably
say i would preach that as a true
statement
purely because it's a case of like
as a woman you go through like a certain
stage in your life right
i've got cheated on
so i'm gonna go do the same thing but
times ten
so i would agree with that now i would
say like
a whole i would not i would not agree
with that purely because it's like
as a woman like
you have the right to make the wrongs
right the same way a man has the right
to make wrongs right
and as a person you can look
i can have x amount of sexual partners
this is what a woman has but in our day
in society as a man
if you have x amount of partners you're
considered as a lad as a
as a player as a you know as a guy right
whereas if a woman has an x amount of
partners she's a [ __ ] she's whatever
that's why nowadays it's like i was
seriously thinking about like the
woman's point of view purely for the
fact that like
as a woman if you have x amount of
partners
it's okay
because of the fact that like if you're
looking from a man's perspective
it's a bit i would say it's okay but
it's understandable yeah i think this
way you gotta be graceful at the same
time you see because
it's cause and effect yeah absolutely
it's easy this is where like i was
saying before when kevin samuel says who
taught you to be your wife but they have
the structure to be taught how to be a
wife right and this is where we have to
have grace for both sexes both male and
females you see so well i think you know
it's like men's
like they talked about like men's they
rated like based on sexual partners men
and women's um
marital happiness and i'm pretty sure
though the highest was both had zero
okay that was that was the highest
amount
even like yeah they both like men and
women have only slept with each other
right but on the flip end it was like
between like a guy who's had like two
sexual partners and a guy who's had
eight like the guy with eight had a
higher marital satisfaction where the
women with like less
like their satisfaction dropped the more
partners they have yeah yes like i think
it was like 80 like your chance of being
a happy marriage if you're a virgin is
like 80 and it drops down to like
i don't remember what it dropped out i'm
butchering this but it was like at least
at least below 50 i think it was 30 40.
well if one was a virgin chance of
happiness is it like so they surveyed
people i'm butchering this okay but they
surveyed people on their marital
happiness after x amount of years right
yeah and then they surveyed them on
their sexual partners okay and for men
it didn't really have like their their
number of sexual partners didn't really
have an effect
on like like their happiness not not
significantly right and i i want to say
i think the happiest still was zero
partners for both right that's the ideal
yeah however okay however
like men's didn't really change were
women if they were not a virgin so like
if she's a virgin she has an 80 chance
of a happy marriage but if she's had
like two three or four this chance that
she could get highly divorced i think
i've seen that yeah and i i'm pretty
sure it when it goes from like 80 and if
she said five or more it's like she's a
30 chance of a happy marriage so it goes
it drops down significantly i was the
only thing i was gonna add to that is
like and this is i'm gonna say about a
month ago that i've seen this um
it was a case of like
um what would you rather do right so
would you rather have a person
that you know slept with a hundred men
or
would you rather have a person that you
don't know slept with like 10 men but
it's hurt like you know what i mean and
i asked you that question you did that's
me
um and then most of the guys obviously
would rather have the person that had
less men yeah but without knowing what
would you do
in that situation so repeat the question
solo so would you rather have
knowingly would you have a woman that
had slept with like over 100 men yes or
without knowing would you rather have a
woman that's left with 10 men without
knowing
wait huh um
so wait so the hunt like
he knows she has a hundred guys yes and
then no body count so there's
okay okay so one girl's body counts a
lot he knows yeah the second girl would
you rather have a girl that you don't
know how many x amount you don't know
you don't know but like like 10 was the
actual you know yeah i probably wouldn't
go over one i do not know because at
least i wouldn't have that thing in my
head that's exactly that's definitely
that's what most men would go but the
problem is that if she's had so many
sexual partners the problem is that
what's the comparison and that's why a
man
less one she has nothing to compare it
to so you have more chocolate problems
so exactly so next next question i have
for you two girls right and i think i've
asked you this before no way
so so you have two girls to pick from
one girl has slept with that's
let's say 25 30 guys but you don't know
any of them and you will never know them
you'll never meet them in your life they
were let's say she went to school
on the west coast okay you'll never
whatever i love the way you're being
specific with west coast because i've
heard about west coast
now second girl
she's slept with um
let's let's say five guys okay let's
but one of them
you know and you know well and you'll
always have to see him forever yeah it
was years ago yeah she
she's over she it was mutual but
you know him yeah which girl do you pick
tough one
it's a very tough one let me know in the
comments who do you pick it's a
situation it's a situation with bad and
worse
i'll probably go with the
person that's
caveat let's see if i'm single yeah yeah
with the person that
probably has slept with my friend but
only had five okay yeah because i'm
sorry i couldn't
probably work with that okay compared to
100 because it's like what's the
comparison you know right yeah so it's
about you know it's it's choosing
between two bad options a bad option and
a worse option right yeah i'm sorry but
i can't no the thing is
as a golden rule like and this is
reaching into the bro code right yeah as
a bro right uh-huh if let's say for
example um
if i have a girlfriend or not a
girlfriend but just a girl that i've
slept with right and as a bro
you've somehow managed to stumble upon
her and you slept with her and i told
you
as a bro it's kind of like for me
personally bro code wise i would i
couldn't do it yeah what if it was your
what if it was years ago it doesn't
matter it doesn't matter it doesn't
matter it's just broke
i'm sorry bro i just it's just bro code
broco i think like
girls it's just
girls date each other's like ex like oh
my gosh there's so many girls on the on
my team in college that like slept with
the same guy and like one of them dated
like that happened a lot but it's like
the 2080 rule right the 20
okay next
now i'm so i'm surprised you picked the
so you would pick the girl that had the
30.
now how would my note because of things
mentality-wise look i would much rather
look because obviously i would live by
the mentality of
if i do what you know if it's not broken
don't fix something meaning wise
before me i i know fully well that
you've obviously had a girlfriend or a
boyfriend right right and you've slept
with them right that's understand that's
a god given
but
i always also live by a role of like
it's not
uh what you call it what's the thing
goes it's not
yours it's your turn okay
it's not yours it's your turn
it's like
if i don't get married to you in that
moment in time or if i don't go and we
live a happy life after yeah someone
else will take my place the same way i
took someone else's place right off the
show right you know what i mean yeah
yeah right that's right that's the way
it
is the whole point is that what's the
chance of me parabonding with the woman
right one with less is more likely than
the one with many that's why i would
choose that option both of crap options
but you know what i heard that's the
most true thing rolo tomasi said it's
not it's not about the number it's about
the number of like alphas or like the
number of like improv whatever it's like
and because i know girls that have like
a low body count right but like that one
guy they always like want to go back too
yeah and then that one guy they always
yeah i mean
no i'm gonna tell you this story so this
is a girl from
people start looking up these people i'm
not going to say where i know yes
but so she
actually whatever college okay
so she went
with a guy her freshman year college
dated this man for like a month okay
super into him now this i didn't really
get it he was like five seven i'm like
you can't be tripping over guys
sorry no offense guys
but okay so
and like a like kind of a loser like i
didn't get this okay but she was all all
into this guy breaks her heart cheats
whatever
a couple years later she's dating a new
guy this man bought her a house bought
her a house okay i went to a party and i
don't this girl really didn't sleep
around that much like she was she she
didn't wasn't that big of a dream she
wasn't like you you would not you would
never never have guessed
at a party i'm there i'm in the basement
i see her while she's dating this like
the guy who bought her the house walk
out of the bathroom
with
this the guy from fresh freshman year
does that make sense so she was hooking
up with this other guy and her boyfriend
came to this party like 45 minutes later
oh and that's what i was saying like you
would never guess but she was like the
alpha alpha widow yeah wow
and i was like
no one would have ever guessed but
that's what i think no no [ __ ] that
because that's an american thing
i'm sorry like you can
deny that but
i've been an american in one year but i
was there enough to find out
put it to you this way right
i had no girlfriends i had no connection
with america before going there right as
soon as i got went there i went on to
the
i think it was like yuba whatever
one of the dating sites right
within five minutes i had this one go
and then another one and another one and
then another one and then another one
right
back-to-back from all the same
university same college the same thing
as a man i was
18 at a time my house yeah
i
i spoke to all of them
wait so you think that women are
[ __ ] in america
listen like it's okay that's a proof
yes yeah i look lola you can't you can't
blame but like it is it's true
for no
to a certain extent
to people that are from america you have
to look good a certain way but
in europe and this is coming from like i
never believed it but forgot proven
right because i was an european
with an accent
it got an easier i never believed that
was true until it was true yeah that's
all i'm saying girls love british
accents
[Music]
okay i'll tell you the difference in
british and american men british men
dress better usually
typically
british men
yeah i would say they dress better
they're they're taller that's the thing
in london it's like it's a no
yeah
i'm positive it's like no no in london
it's 15 of guys in the u.s are over six
foot but in london like 30 percent of
guys over 25 or six foot
well i didn't know that
no me and my friends were talking about
that so i think higher school-wise and
college-wise but they're not actually
bigger like
yeah no no no no no no they're higher
from like they they do tend to be higher
from college-wise and high school-wise
but specifically like if i'm making a
business wise like like a grown man
they're not sure they're actually sure
but
um
yeah that's my that's i would say the
biggest differences are the accents i
think it's just like different my
favorite is australian personally
but
but i get the same thing here like guys
always tell me they like my accent and
they like like listening to me i get
that all this that's so fun i love it
like cliche as much as a cliche i like
the american accent not because of like
anything else it's just like it's a bit
like you know because like look in
england the same way in uk in us right
you still have like the uh the asian
accent and whatever like you still have
like a culture action the same way here
but i just love the america accent from
a very young i don't know whether that's
because i wanted to go to america so bad
when i was younger right but once i made
it i like i just love the american
accent i've always loved it and with me
personally i've always been able to
adapt to an accent um early
meaning like
if you speak a certain way i will do
everything in my power not in a rude way
but i will do everything that i can to
match your pitch oh that's because well
and you kind of sound british even
though you're not it's
i love south london now i was there
first so i love south london i was bored
around culture yeah i know how to as
believe it or not right now if i show
you my music playlist or if i told you i
can make jello fries would you believe
me
yes
exactly exactly my exactly what most
people have like the reaction better
than me bro fries chicken um
and uh like
pizza like no no like uh what was it um
not peter uh what the [ __ ] is it called
um patty okay yes okay
yeah i connect all three of them and
most people don't believe me that but
when i make this a little bit like yo
like what the [ __ ] are you doing like
where did you buy it from yeah because
it's like i've been raised around so
much culture mm-hmm when i the first
white friend story that i've had was
when i first moved to east london yeah
other than that
uh nigerian african
like just black
and it was so you guys gotta go closer
to the legs i'm sorry
um okay guys thank you for the super
chats we got some super chat let's go
so we got catholic mass two dollars i
admit it i'm boring
you're not boring we love you thank you
a five seven guy two dollars well i
guess i won't be taking pearly to the
dance i'm sorry i'm sorry i already got
dibs on that i'm not gonna lie
i'm apologize but i haven't got dibs on
that we're going to a dance absolutely
where
oh we're going up to shoreditch you know
absolutely
now
um
watching okay i think that's all of the
super chats well i thought this was a
fun show you guys have fun really nice
yeah absolutely
because this is probably my first ever
podcast i've ever done so it's all right
you know i'm sorry tell me tell do you
guys have any final thoughts
uh i just think um the sort of gender
wars that we're currently having at the
current moment at the time i just think
if we just focus on our responsibilities
mm-hmm i think that's all we can do
focus what we can control not what we
can't control when we have the mindset
of trying to change our people this is
where we get into trouble mm-hmm i can
only be the person i can be i can't
change any other person
be the be the change you want to see in
the world like gandhi would say oh
i wasn't gonna say that
no but yeah no honestly like
we can't predict the future no one else
can like you know what he's like it's
the whole thing of like yesterday's a
mystery sorry yesterday's history
tomorrow is a mystery today is a gift
you know what i'm saying so it's like
you do what you can do in that moment in
time don't be a person that's like
planning into the future you can
plan a holiday plan something but you
can't plan like look i can die god
forbid i die tomorrow
just focus on what you got to do and
by the will of god it will work out to
you you know what i'm saying that's
that's the only thing that i can say
and tell them where they can find you
again
tell them well you can find me look i've
mentioned my um instagram at the start
but my other instagram is why possible
uh at uh underscore fitness
that's my um business if anyone wants to
get fit
give me a shout i'll be there for you
yeah and my twitter is ini ini jk27 is
on twitter my instagram is ini
ini1983 don't nobody be usually no
twitter no more
okay guys um do not forget to subscribe
to the channel okay please do guys like
i'm i'm for real this ain't it's not
cool to watch and not subscribe it's
beef on site no it's beef it takes two
seconds hit that subscribe button like
god damn
and guys you really should consider
buying the meal plan i promise you like
i'm i'm gonna be like skinny this summer
i'm not gonna lie to you i'm on it
just do it trust the process
um
don't forget to subscribe ring that
notification bell and we'll talk to you
guys next time